[Music]
on this Saturday night the fight for
migrant workers in Canada are their
labor rights being neglected during this
health crisis Beijing tells Ottawa to
butt out after Canada suspends its
extradition treaty with Hong Kong plus
subdued celebrations this July 4th
weekend as another person in the
president's inner circle tests positive
for Cova 19 we don't appreciate a bunch
of you coming here at Greg Baker job and
the cabbie who had to listen to this
while asking a fare to wear a mask
global national would Robin Gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with a call to
action across this country to protect
migrant workers and other non permanent
residents protests took place in several
cities demanding the federal government
do more to help temporary foreign
workers international students and
refugees many of them have been on the
front lines of the Cova 19 pandemic
they've been doing work deemed as
essential but protesters say the
Canadian government is failing them
David aken reports they gathered in
Montreal in Richmond BC and in Toronto a
motet to their pleas asking that we get
full immigration status no full
immigration status will mean better
health protection and labor rights for
temporary foreign workers refugees and
international students we are talking
about over a million and a half people
one in 23 people in this country are
either temporary or undocumented
activists say the pandemic has
highlighted how vulnerable this group is
in the last week there has been a
particular focus on temporary foreign
workers in the agricultural sector
mostly in Ontario Quebec in BC Essex
County in southwestern Ontario has been
the hot spot of a recent health crisis
the Windsor Essex County Health Unit
says 688 farm workers there have kovat
19 including 191 on one farm alone
Ontario Premier Doug Ford dispatched
emergency management personnel to deal
with the outbreak and to make sure farms
can keep producing food food is critical
and we're going to get over this we're
gonna get it resolved because everyone's
working together and it's it's no one's
no one's fault it's it's this covet
nineteen came in there and and we're
locking it down and well activists have
been pushing for better conditions for
the 50,000 or so migrant farmworkers
they say the half-a-million temporary
foreign workers and other sectors also
need protection these are essential
workers from the construction worker to
the cleaner to the uber driver to the
health care worker to the farm worker to
the domestic worker to the student to
the warehouse
we are essential we are what sustains
Canada and ourselves the federal
government is sympathetic to the cause
we recognize there is more to do to
protect temporary foreign workers in
Canada Immigration Minister Marco
mendocino said in a statement we
continue to strengthen inspections and
are committed to looking at additional
steps we can take on the street though
these protesters are pushing for action
now David akin Global News Ottawa police
in Quebec say a fourth person has died
following a horrific Canada Day tractor
accident southeast of Montreal the
accident had already claimed the lives
of three young children all under the
age of seven now one of the two adults
listed in critical condition has also
died the victims were among 10 people
who rejected from a tractor while riding
in its front loader a 38 year old man is
charged with criminal negligence causing
death and bodily harm
diplomatic tensions between Ottawa and
Beijing show no sign of easing yesterday
Canada suspended its extradition treaty
with Hong Kong over China's new security
law that imposes harsh limits on dissent
in Hong Kong today the Chinese embassy
in Ottawa accused the federal government
of foreign interference a statement
posted on its website reads some Western
countries including Canada have been
meddling in Hong Kong affairs under the
pretext of human rights which seriously
violates international law and basic
norms of international relations and
fully exposes their double standards on
the issues of national security the
strain between Canada and China is one
of the topics tomorrow on the West block
we'll speak to a top China security
analyst on the case of the two Canadians
detained in Beijing and the arrest among
Wong Jo in Vancouver Boni Glazer
explains why sending hmong back to China
could do irreparable harm to this
country violating this arrangement would
be damaging to Canada's reputation I
think that the US and other countries
would likely view Canada as potentially
untrustworthy and the resulting mistress
would persist regardless of the outcome
of the presidential election in the
United States in
November will also be looking at the
financial situation here in Canada as
the Trudeau government gears up to
provide a fiscal snapshot next week
Canada has been spending billions to
keep the economy afloat the 2019 2020
deficit was projected to be twenty six
point six billion dollars and expected
to improve to eleven point six billion
by 2024 2025 the Parliamentary Budget
Officer is now forecasting a 256 billion
dollar deficit for this year the
government is gonna have to find a way
to walk that line of gradually opening
up the economy and turning to the issue
of economic recovery and I say that just
because of the inordinately
we've got to get people back to work we
got to get that unemployment rate down
I'm sitting in for Mercedes Stevenson
tomorrow on the West block bringing it
to you from the west coast please be
sure to join us with our special
broadcast in Vancouver
today Prince Edward Island reported
three new cases of copán 19 for the
first time since late april and they're
linked to travel the provinces chief
public health officer says the three
cases include a woman who works at a
seniors home in Charlottetown
who is connected to a man in his 20s who
traveled to Nova Scotia and came into
contact with someone from the United
States it's Independence Day like no
other in America many beaches are closed
and fireworks have been canceled
in the worst-hit country 33 states are
seeing a rise in Cova 19 cases and
despite that Donald Trump continues to
hold holiday rallies where people aren't
wearing masks and aren't physically
distancing Jennifer Johnson reports an
independence day like never before in
the u.s. fireworks and large
celebrations canceled beaches from coast
to coast closed in some cases barricades
have been put up to keep people away I
feel that they're unnecessary Maine's
open air out here boardwalks and bars in
several states are also shut down on
this busiest weekend of the summer this
is my my biggest dollar weekend of the
year
normally Kovan 19 continues to spread in
over 30 states more than 200,000
Americans have tested positive for the
virus since Monday
Florida shattered a new record of
11500 new cases in a single day it's
unprecedented and every single day
brings new experiences I know it sounds
cliche and trite but that's absolutely
the case while millions of Americans
celebrate the 4th of July local
officials are begging them to take
precautions just hammering home the
message wear your mask some beaches that
were allowed to stay open are packed
Myrtle Beach in South Carolina this one
in San Diego as both states battle
rapidly increase in cases doctors say
there will be a price to pay for all
these closed gatherings will see
hospitalizations continue to go up and
unfortunately I think we're also going
to see the number of deaths start to
rise again the virus is not stopping US
President Donald Trump from celebrating
the country's Independence Friday night
over 7,000 gathered to cheer him on at
Mount Rushmore his message not about
covin 19 but what he calls a left-wing
cultural revolution in our schools our
newsrooms even our corporate boardrooms
there is a new far-left fascism that
demands absolute allegiance the people
in the audience were all seated close
together a few wearing masks the same is
feared in Washington as it holds its
annual 4th of July fireworks
extravaganza the mayor has asked people
to stay home and watch the event on TV
but president Trump has invited hundreds
of his supporters to watch from the
South Lawn of the White House Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington
a scare for the American president and
his inner circle tonight his top
campaign fundraiser who is also his
son's girlfriend has tested positive for
Koba 19 kimberly guilfoyle is reportedly
asymptomatic she's the third person in
direct contact with president Trump
who's contracted Cova 19 both Gilfoyle
and Donald Trump jr. are now isolating
themselves and have canceled all
upcoming public events for months
medical experts around the world have
been warning people to wear a mask if
they want to stay safe and struggle to
stay at least 2 metres apart but in the
United States wearing a mask has become
a political issue even the president
refuses to follow the advice of his own
coronavirus task force
regi Cecchini reports an everyday piece
of protective equipment has become one
of the most divisive issues in America
it's gotten to the point where wearing a
mask somehow has become a political
statement
health experts including members of the
White House coronavirus Task Force have
urged people to cover their faces when
in public there's no doubt that wearing
masks protects you and gets you to be
protected but not everybody needs the
advice the fact that Trump is not
wearing a mask fits his coalition
beautifully they're strongly
anti-government they're opposed to rules
from on high but playing politics with
this pandemic may have caused Americans
their lives all for the sake of not
wanting to be told what to do his
supporters are disproportionately male
and blue-collar
and to them this is a question of
machismo are they manly enough to go out
without a a mascot president Trump often
charts his own course but he's faced
sharp criticism for a defiant attitude
during this health crisis this is not a
confusing issue we are in a pandemic and
if we want to prevent this pandemic and
get people back to work and get kids
back to school people have to put their
masks on recent rallies held by the
president put thousands of people at
risk after public health was ignored no
masks in the crowd or on stage it's his
decision whether to wear a mask in the
early months of the pandemic Trump's
decision to go mask free was followed by
those who rely on his political magic
touch but his Kovach 19 cases spiked a
break in the Republican ranks formed
with many lawmakers appearing in public
with their faces covered president Trump
is now the odd man out if he were to do
that simple thing it would really
encourage people to actually do the
right thing there's a strong partisan
divide when wearing masks 7 and 10
Democrats say they wear a mask when
outdoors or in stores compared to 56
percent of Republicans overall 65% of
all adults admit to wearing a mask face
coverings have now added to the growing
divide that exists in America people
simply line up for or against Trump and
that deter
views the US election is roughly 120
days away and Trump is struggling in
polls
experts say by covering up his face the
president could uncover public support
Reggie Cecchini Global News Washington
it's back to business in England for
hair salons restaurants and most
importantly for some the pub's it's
beautiful just to give an update as of
6:00 a.m. local time any establishments
were finally allowed to reopen their
doors for the first time in more than
three months cinemas theme parks and
churches can also open up but all
businesses must take precautions to
prevent the spread of Kovan 19 the UK
suffered the worst hit from the pandemic
in Western Europe with more than two
hundred and eighty six thousand
confirmed cases and more than 44,000
deaths the Prime Minister welcomed the
latest steps to reopen the economy but
warned people to play it safe we think
we're in good shape but my message is
let's not blow it now folks we've done a
fantastic job so far in bearing down on
this disease collectively let's not blow
it now
Northern Ireland already allowed the
pints to be poured starting yesterday
Wales is keeping its pubs and
restaurants closed until July 13th but
only reopening for outdoor service at
that time Scotland is opening up for
outdoor service on Monday but customers
will have to wait for July 15th for a
seat inside coming up the racist abuse
this cabbie had to endure and why he's
speaking out
you
in Halifax video of a verbal attack
inside a taxi is getting a lot of
attention tonight the footage shows a
passenger hurling racially charged
insult at the driver the passenger has
not been charged but as Alexa McLean
reports both the public and some
politicians want to know why call deep
Dona immigrated to Canada from India in
2007 he became a Canadian citizen
shortly after and raised his family in
Halifax he's been a taxi driver in the
city for more than a decade like many
the pandemic has him concerned about
workplace safety and says it is what
caused him to react when a recent
passenger began coughing in his backseat
he scared me so I just tell him the next
time when you call a taxi please avail
your mosque especially in the taxi
there's a note not a much a distance
masks aren't mandatory in Halifax taxis
but Donna says his request triggered a
verbal assault that included racial
slurs they say yo [ __ ] immigrant to
steal our jobs away from us I'm Canadian
so and the Canada they still need
immigrants so so not me not the exchange
was captured on the taxis camera the
passenger has not been identified
I'm calling not Donna says when he first
contacted police they told him to simply
ignore the man Donna said he had video
proof of the incident happening and
insisted that officers respond to the
scene John New Brunswick Mayor Don
Darlene says Donna's story ties in with
emotion that aims to make racial
discrimination a punishable offense
we're calling on the federal government
to make changes to the Criminal Code of
Canada or calling on the provincial
government to need to use every tool
they have to make these types of
behaviors illegal Donna and his fan
say they want all black indigenous and
persons of color to feel safe in their
environments so my message is just don't
ignore what if somebody tells you just
to raise your voice
Alexa McLean Global News Halifax
Cleveland's major league baseball team
has made a pitch to change its official
name the name Indians has racist
connotations and is considered a slur
against indigenous people the team says
the recent unrest in our community and
our country has only underscored the
need for us to keep improving as an
organization on issues of social justice
doubling danger still ahead the dire
warning as to health disasters merge
you are watching global national the
Copa 19 pandemic is forcing the World
Food Program to launch its biggest
humanitarian response in history the
United Nations agency fears 270 million
people could be acutely food insecure
before the end of this year as Redman
Shannon explains this comes as millions
of displaced Syrians are still in need
of humanitarian aid and a warning the
story contains disturbing images Sawa is
5 years old but weighs the same as a
newborn baby in Yemen her agony is
nothing unusual UNICEF says 2.4 million
kids could be malnourished by the end of
this year a war long ignored by much of
the world now made worse by the
challenges of a pandemic it was a
massive problem anyway in a country like
Yemen but now there are going to be so
many people needing assistance and
needing help in 2019 the World Food
Programme helped a record 97 million
people worldwide it says that has risen
to 138 million this year and the number
could almost double by the end of 2020
but our traditional donors a lot of them
like Canada like the United Kingdom
United States ain't going to be worrying
about their own economies in six months
hunger had been worsened in recent years
by conflict and climate many of the
people at risk this year are in
countries where food is not normally an
issue if your hard-working taxi driver
in slum somewhere and you can't go out
to work you won't get paid you won't be
able to feed your family in India
internal migrant workers suddenly had to
rely on donations when the country went
into lockdown
to make matters even worse locust
invasions have destroyed crops in the
subcontinent and elsewhere but some of
the greatest suffering continues to be
in Syria and among Syrian refugees
talking about Syrian refugees about 50%
of those that had a job now do not have
it anymore a conference this week looked
to plug huge shortfalls in Syrian aid
the total pledge amounts in a row to six
point nine billion that makes it in US
dollars seven point seven billion that's
still less than what the UN says it
needs eight agencies say the price of
food in Syria has skyrocketed and warned
that a new refugee crisis from the
country could be triggered if the
problems there are ignored Redman
Shannon Global News London
up next the first-ever report on
something uniquely Canadian
Canadian researchers have uncovered an
ancient mind dating back 12,000 years in
dark submerged caves near Mexico City
the scientists believe it was used to
mine red ochre the clay like mineral was
prized by prehistoric people and used as
body decoration sun protection and for
burials this discovery may explain how
the remains of a young woman who died
13,000 years ago ended up in the cave
there are hundreds of animals unique to
our country but no one has ever created
an official list until now that is
as Linda Ellsworth explains the report
is giving one province major bragging
rights and major responsibility anyone
who lives in British Columbia already
knows it's special in many ways one of
them pointed out in a report by the
Nature Conservancy of Canada nobody has
ever recorded her catalog a list of
purely Canadian species that are only
ours and nowhere else in the world
what makes BC stand out is that we are
home to over a third of the countries
308 endemic species the reason is due in
part to some geographical good luck a
few tens of thousands of years ago
during the last glacial period it's
thought that Vancouver Island and Haida
Gwaii remained ice-free and so that
allowed species to live there while
other areas are covering ice so that
means they have small populations and
they're restricted to very small areas
so that's why these spots have to be
protected
ninety percent of Canada's endemic
animal and plant species are vulnerable
to extinction they're not that well
understood and the ones that we do know
of and have said you are not doing that
well because they are very restricted in
their population and so the goal of the
report which is available on the Nature
Conservancy of Canada's website is to
better enable their protection that's
why it's important to identify clearly
where they're located so it helps inform
levels of governments and conservation
groups in terms of next steps because
these all we live here we have a
responsibility to protect them
and I knew there's lots we could learn
Linda Ellsworth global news and that is
global national for this Saturday I'm
Robin Gill tonight your Canada is mostly
Alberta we would love to see your corner
of this country so email your photos to
viewers at global national calm thank
you for watching and I'll see you back
here tomorrow good night
[Music]
you